good morning John uh there's something
about this isn't there Catherine turned
to me after finishing your video from
this week and she said I was engaged
but I was relaxed I think the way we
normally do these videos like isn't
precisely that I mean I'm not gonna stop
doing it this way I like this way this
is the way this is the way but I don't
think it's relaxing and like I'm getting
older maybe the level of energy needs to
come down a little bit sometimes a
hamstring has to be the most
ridiculously named muscle right there
can't be a worse one than that Cath is
weird like it's just uh somebody looked
at that and was like that looks like a
small cow but at least kath is like a
living animal if it were called a veal
string
then I'd be like yeah that's equally
ridiculous to hamstring that's that's
the basic of the situation we're in with
hamstring that's got to be the weirdest
one I've been working on project for
awesome perks because it's uh it's going
up quick for the last four or five years
we've been making various kinds of spray
paint art where we've been using
stencils on glass or canvas and when we
were doing that we also made something
by accident every year I used the same
roll of paper
as the drop cloth so he wouldn't get
paint on whatever surface we were
painting on and over the years that
paper became really beautiful like it
had all the stencil marks and then it
had scuffs and Footprints and some of it
started to rip and it was just like
clear that we weren't going to use this
paper again and and I literally like
looked down at it in the dumpster and I
was like I
I can't throw that away I took it home
and I cut out squares
uh and then I graffiti mopped hangler
fish on a bunch of them and they are the
hanger fish art this year and they're
all signed and numbered there's 250 of
them and I'm excited
to share them with people and of course
it's the only time we're going to be
able to do ones like this because
that paper
doesn't exist anymore it's a pretty good
trade though I think and next year I'll
have to figure out something else to do
I'm not sure if that's not an optimistic
or depressing
um
but I guess that's what figuring out
something else to do is both of those
things so I have a friend she's a pretty
good friend and I go over to her place
fairly frequently
um and uh and she knows my name which is
weird that I mentioned that go over to
her place once to to meet a new member
of her family she's got a new dog it's
extremely cute brand new dog didn't
exist a couple months ago and she's like
this is Hank meet Hank uh what
what am I supposed to do with this like
either this is an odd honor that is
being bestowed on me or you forgot I
existed this isn't a dog that came from
the pound with a name this is a new dog
that you had an infinite number of names
that you could have given I'm not
personally a name dogs human names kind
of person I my dog was named lemon my
cats have been named Cameo and gummy
bear we don't run into that problem very
often when someone shows up and they're
like oh my name's gummy bear too you can
do it I just think like avoid the names
of people who are going to be at your
house a lot and soon sorry it's true if
you're watching this
um just know that I never said anything
and then it just sort of pinged around
in there for years
until this I forgot about gluteus
maximus gluteus maximus is definitely
the most ridiculous name for a gluteus
maximus like your butt is the emperor of
Rome gluteus maximus runs
[Music]
and
I like to say if it ain't folk don't
Blix it
it's just funnier
John I'll see you tomorrow